jack dorsey and michael saylor recently
sat down to talk about bitcoin and jack
explained exactly why bitcoin will live
forever here's exactly what he said
100
yeah but and and the most important
thing is you can see it you can see how
it was built you can see the
instructions with which it's built you
can see how it runs you can see the past
history of disagreements and how
resilient resilient it's been to attacks
both
political
government
uh individual greed it's it's resisted
and been resilient to nearly every
attack and they're more to come
but i have no doubt that the model
itself the development model the
operational model will solve the
problems it faces better than any other
development model i've seen in my life
there you have it jack dorsey explaining
exactly why bitcoin is resilient why it
is not susceptible to these external
attacks bitcoin is built to be durable
and to survive forever ultimately
bitcoin is a decentralized digital
currency it has the most decentralized
computer network in the world it also
has the strongest computer network in
the world all of the design decisions
all of the foundations of which bitcoin
is built on both from a technical
standpoint and also the ethos drive that
long-term sustainability of the asset
bitcoin is trying to serve as a global
store of value it has high aspirations
and in order to get there it has to be
secure it has to be durable and it has
to last forever bitcoin's on that path
now and i think the way that jack dorsey
just described it is a perfect example
of why bitcoin stands out from the rest
of the cryptocurrencies bitcoin is
different bitcoin is decentralized
bitcoin is secure and ultimately bitcoin
is built to last